Glenn Greenwald is the host of system
update he joins us tonight Glenn thanks
so much for coming on
um I'm I'm actually in some ways glad
that they went after a group of people I
you know probably don't agree with on a
lot of things because it just makes it
so much clearer this is not partisan
this guy is saying something the regime
doesn't like and they're trying to put
him in jail how is this happening in
America
I think one of the critical things to
remember is even before January 6th my
Administration said their priority is to
launch a domestic war on terror to take
all the tactics we used against al Qaeda
and Isis and foreign terrorist groups
and can direct it inward because they
perceive that anti-establishment
dissonance in America like the person
you just showed are the real enemy and
that's what this is about there's a
foreign agents law that is supposed to
be if you say things you don't really
believe because some foreign government
is paying you millions of dollars to say
them you have to register that's not the
case with these people these are people
who have been radical black leftists for
decades they're not the people the
Democratic party likes they hate the
Biden Administration they're against the
war in Ukraine and they claim that they
found 500 here two thousand dollars
there that have origins in the Russian
government for events they did this is
what we criticize Russia for we fund
opposition groups in Russia and then
Russia says those are foreign agents and
we objectively say a foreign agent is
only somebody saying things the
government a foreign government tells
them to say and now we're using that
same Theory we say Russia makes makes
Russia tyrannical to criminalize dissent
in the United States that's what this
case is about
so what's so interesting about this is
these are not maggot people these are
the victims of systemic racism they're
always lecturing us about right and
their first amendment rights have just
been stripped and they're looking at
jail terms for having opinions Biden
doesn't like
we're the Liberals where's Morning Joe
we're all the sensitive white liberals
to defend these people
they're not well this is my yeah this is
why I'm so glad you're covering this
case Tucker because this is the tactic
that tyrants always use when they want
to implement a an authoritarian
precedent they choose people that makes
others uncomfortable when they wanted to
start Banning people from the internet
that they chose myelianopolis and Alex
Jones because they knew that even
Republicans would say I don't want to
defend those people they're they're a
bridge too far and then the precedent
gets set and they expanded inward again
these are not people the kind of black
radicals Democratic party uh
establishment Representatives like
they're people who attack the Biden
Administration who don't vote Democrat
these are real dissidents and they know
that not even Democrats will defend them
no they're not taking money from Apple
and Facebook they weren't in on the BLM
scam they actually mean it now you're
making me like them Glenn Greenwell I
appreciate your coming on tonight and
getting as you always do to the core
issues Underneath It All thank you
great to be with you talker thanks
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight